the Peter Pan party that's the focus of
tonight's angle
[Music]
imagine if you never had to grow up if
even as an adult you could get up in the
morning knowing that someone more
responsible would take care of you I'm
so glad you came back tonight I might
never have seen you why because I had to
grow up tomorrow grow up
no I won't have it come on where are we
going the Neverland
[Music]
you'll never grow up there
yeah being a kid is just more fun and
carefree especially in a world where
there's so many dangerous monsters out
there most notably climate change and
Biden's interior secretary wants you to
know that Mommy's going to protect you
climate change is the crisis of our
lifetime we have an obligation to Future
generations to make sure that we have a
planet for them to live on and that's
why I'm here and that's why I'm working
incredibly hard to make sure that we can
realize that transition
don't worry Mama's crying but mama's
working hard for you but you need to
listen and you need to behave children
cows and beef they're also very bad for
you and the planet oh God they're
terrible for the planet so you need to
eat healthier boys and girls
but now we've actually updated the old
eat your vegetables line
insects are actually a great source of
protein and nutrients so they can be a
great alternative to meat which gets me
thinking if we were to replace meat with
insects that might just help curb
emissions by cutting on meat production
and ultimately it can help save a planet
from overheating
you go first
and you don't want to burn up do you
left-leaning politicians have always
liked the idea of government sitting in
loco parentis an authority figure like
your parents who will set the rules of
conduct in the rules of language that
you're expected to follow and if you ask
why it's because they told you so we've
introduced the green New Deal for cities
the green New Deal for public schools
and the green New Deal for public
housing just to name a few these bills
not only stop climate change they tackle
the intersecting crises of climate
economic inequality and racial Justice
follow that Venn diagram of course none
of this has anything to do with Justice
it's all about consolidating power
racial Justice the Civil Rights Act
passed almost 60 years ago economic
justice big government just makes that
worse by wasting our money and sending
our jobs overseas
and climate Justice tell it to the
Chinese sweetheart who the Democrats are
making richer day by day
the truth is liberals have failed across
the board you can't campaign on that can
you so now Beyond dividing America along
racial lines all they're left with is
trying to sell voters on accepting a new
lower standard of living in return
Democrats offer them a life of Perpetual
adolescence this is why so many in the
left are thrilled that more States like
Minnesota are pushing marijuana
legalization best to keep them numb and
dumb right that way they won't know how
little Freedom they actually have left
or money
and what says freedom in a country as
vast as ours more than a gas-powered car
on an open road right but mommy and
daddy want to take your way away your
keys permanently or put you in an EV
that traps you every 300 miles at a
charging station with some guy named
Ralph if you can find a charging station
that is
when they told me they were going to put
some electric car charges and I was like
oh great of those six one of them has
completely broken several of them
they're extremely finicky about exactly
how you have to plug it in it's insane
it's like if the wind blows too hard I
get a notification on my phone saying
your car stopped charging
and Vox is telling Middle America that
it's time to ditch your car altogether
because it's better for the planet don't
you know it's better for individual
health and it's a way of avoiding car
crashes
plus it's too expensive kids
of course Biden's war on oil and gas
drilling has been a direct assault on
everyone's wallet but you shouldn't
worry because if liberals have their way
you won't need to provide for your
family anyway because big families are
bad for Mother Earth
and marriage wow many have come to
believe it isn't the ideal because to
say it is the ideal offend someone
somewhere
Democrats are scrambling to get Young
Americans to invert the old idea of the
American dream which is marriage family
home maybe a few cars
in Biden world it's all too expensive
especially with wages declining so their
allies are feverishly promoting
alternative ways of making ends meet
and it's not one family home ownership
this is called the member wall and on
this side of the wall is all the current
members there are 20 people that live in
this house one cool thing about living
in a communal house is that everything
is shared for example this pan is a
shared house pan everyone has so much to
offer and so much to share growing up in
a Modern Family the house is almost like
an extension of that
you see the size of that kitchen that's
like from college days oh It's Like
Preschool though for adults share
children share but really in this Peter
Pan where all Democrats are creating you
never have to actually even go to work
why leave home at all
it is certainly the case that there are
fewer people in the building any given
day uh than there were pre-pandemic and
telework has become an important
dimension of how they work there will be
substantial taxpayer savings from right
sizing our office footprint right sizing
they're just making up phrases now
bye-bye cities you're not going to exist
any longer because no one's coming into
them I guess we're going to figure that
one out later though now the fact is the
Democrats are cruel they're
impoverishing millions of hard-working
Americans and pretending they aren't
who knows how many will live without AC
this summer just like they went without
sufficient Heat this winter all because
of rising fuel costs
I believe energy poverty is a good thing
I don't know the term ma'am you've never
heard of the phrase energy poverty
I have not heard of that term but I uh
it's probably pretty self-explanatory
though don't you think well I think what
we're really trying to do with our clean
energy goals is make energy more
affordable and make the American people
more miserable
so yes the Democrats are determined to
keep young people weak poor frightened
and alone they don't want you to get
married they don't want you to go out to
work they don't want you to have kids
they want you at home smoking pot
playing video games and spending the
rest of your life as a 12 year old
we all know stories of young people who
don't want to grow up but I really don't
believe that most Young Americans want
to spend the rest of their lives feeling
sorry for themselves they want to grow
up they want responsibility and they
want better lives for themselves and
someday yes for their children
so here at the angle our motto is no
American left behind and that includes
Young Americans we have to help them
overcome that despair that the Democrats
are selling if you grew up in the 1970s
you know what it's like to be young in a
world where the president is a hapless
Guy where the enemies of America are on
the March and even the adults seem to
have given up on the country that time
was scary and it was discouraging and I
remember it and for young people in the
80s President Reagan it was a breath of
fresh air he believed that we could all
do better and we still can
most of the so-called problems the
Democrats are talking about the end of
the planet threats of democracy and all
the like they're simply made up and the
real problems we Face a weak economy
arising China open borders can all be
addressed with the right policies we've
seen it before just a few years ago
so we shouldn't concede any young voters
to the Democrats no way let's explain
how things can get better and let's
encourage them to take on adult
responsibilities
because childhood is great
but only for children
and that's the angle hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else